vous êtes le client idéal pour un anti
portrait chinois lumière on ne bouge pas
rien
donc le portrait chinois c'est subjectif
leur jeu sera un mieux lotis secteur
landry portrait chinois elle c'est pour
ça que ça vous convient très bien
si vous étiez un défaut cgt un défaut la
passion une injure bush une maladie la
déception un accident tombés dans le
domaine public
une perversion levis une guerre la paix
si vous étiez un vice interversion si
vous étiez une trahison l'amitié si vous
étiez une arme un cutter si vous étiez
un supplice chinois
c'est une cicatrice le signe de croix
si vous étiez un poison les médias
si vous étiez un [ __ ] encore bouche
si vous étiez un impôt taxation sur
l'indifférence c'est étiez une panne de
sens si vous étiez un dictateur
mon sexe si vous étiez une infirmité
ma violence je suis était un assassin
moi même si vous étiez un microbe le
boycott us il interruptus si vous êtes
chez rim plus celle du couteau si vous
étiez un fléau le manque d'espoir sit-in
torture l'absence d'interview une
humiliation faire partie du monde
littéraire
si vous étiez un terroriste jésus-christ